joe biden has been very clear
if you call into question the results of
our election you are weakening the
foundations of our sacred democracy
unless you are a democrat who is down in
the polls in which case all of the
elections are a sham
a moment ago you were asked whether or
not you believed that we would have free
and fair elections in 2022 if some of
the state legislatures reforms their
voting protocols
you said that it depends
do you
do you think that
they would in any way be illegitimate
oh yeah i think it easy could be be
illegitimate imagine
imagine if in fact trump has succeeded
in convincing pence to not count the
votes
imagine if
in regards to 2022 sir the middle 2052 i
mean
imagine if
those uh attempts to say that uh
the count was not legit
you have to recount it and we're not
going to count we're going to discard
the following votes i mean sure
i'm not saying it's going to be legit
it's the increase
in the prospect of being illegitimate is
the direct proportion of us not being
able to get these
these reforms passed
i'm not saying it's going to be legit
yeah if the republicans get their way it
could easily not be legitimate the
elections that are our sacred are sacred
democracy the best part about this is
that it exposes not just the democrats
for the power hungry monsters that they
are but the squish republicans the
republicans for joe biden
for the sanctimonious disingenuous
little twerps that they always were
because what we were told by all the
squishes was look we might disagree with
joe biden and the democrats on policy
issues but there's something more
fundamental at stake this is the
argument that liz cheney and adam
kinzinger were making there's something
fundamental our democracy and so for the
good of our democracy we need to elect a
man who is civil a man who is mature a
man using responsible rhetoric who's not
going to tear down the very fabric of
our democracy and then it turns out that
on every single count when you compare
biden and trump on every count on
rhetoric on corruption on scandal forget
policy for a second where trump
obviously is light years ahead of of joe
biden but just on all those personal
characteristics it turns out that biden
is worse than trump on every single
count and in some cases he's much much
much worse than trump now he is calling
into question our sacred democracy as
well and the best part of that is that
he's doing it because he knows that his
party is headed toward disaster in
november i'm michael knowles this is the
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from cool papa j
magic who says our democracy really
means their liberal agenda which is why
it's always at stake when conservatives
make any meaningful gains that's true
it's not not just a zinger not just an
accusation that is actually how they
think of
our democracy
so many downsides going around our
society right now this is a great
opportunity to get an upside which is
why i would recommend you check out get
upside are you spending too much money
on gas you are i know that you are
because i see what the prices for gas
are well what if i told you that you
could get 25 cents per gallon cash back
every single time you fill up your tank
well that's not quite true you know
there's always a catch everyone says
look well read the fine print okay
here's the catch here's why that's not
quite true
because on your first fill up you can
actually get 50 cents per gallon
cashback this is an incredible
opportunity do not pass it up go to
get
upside you go to the google play the
apple store
wherever you get your apps you head on
over there you type in get upside
download the free app use my code
knowles k o w l les you will get 50
cents per gallon cash back on your first
fill up and then
you just get the money
it's it's that simple there's no cash
there just cash back goes straight to
your bank account or if you prefer
through paypal or if you prefer an
amazon gift card or a gift card to other
companies
it's a great way to relieve some of that
pressure at the at the pump right now
download the free get upside app use
promo code knowles can wles to get up to
50 cents per gallon cash back on your
first tank that is code knowles so you
know that thing that joe biden just said
you know that thing that he just said
that the 2022 midterms easily could be
illegitimate
well according to white house press
secretary jenn saki
joe biden did not say that you did not
hear that do not believe your lying eyes
these are not the droids you're looking
for a reporter at white house press
briefing said jen hold on joe biden ran
for the past year he's been running on
how trump is the worst guy in the world
because he called into question the
results of our elections now he's doing
the same thing before the elections even
take place how do you make sense of that
jen saki says you didn't hear what you
thought you heard
president biden said the midterm
elections
um both easily could be illegitimate
is he predetermining that the elect the
november elections were going to be
suspect well i talked to the president
about this last night uh and this
morning uh he was not intending to cast
doubt on the legitimacy of the 2020
election he was actually attempting to
make the opposite point which is that in
2020
despite covid despite many attempts to
suppress the vote a record number of
voters democrats and republicans
independents too turned out in the face
of a pandemic and election officials
made sure they could vote and have those
votes counted he was also explaining
that the results would be illegitimate
if states do what the former president
asked them to do in more than a half a
dozen states in 2020
after the 2020 election toss out ballots
and overturn results after the fact and
his view is that what one of the most
important roles we can play now is
informing and educating the public on
what these laws are on efforts to
suppress their vote
and even beyond the laws
efforts in different states across the
country to make it more difficult for
them
get that woman some honey mustard she
has twisted herself into a human pretzel
in this kind of bizarre logic to try to
answer the question at the very end
there the reporter says he goes no no no
jen i'm not talking about 20 20 20. i'm
talking about 2022.
and then she goes on for another three
minutes not answering the question
because it is very clear what joe biden
said he said the 2022 midterm elections
easily could be illegitimate so she says
no no he actually said the opposite of
what he said
no what he actually and then the best
part is she goes on to do the same thing
that joe biden did and just keep talking
about 2020 but that's not
that's not
the issue here so what the democrats
want to be able to do is call into
question the results of an election that
they are most likely going to lose and
lose by a lot
and at the same time keep the moral high
ground of never questioning the
elections because they've spent the past
year accusing democrats or accusing
republicans rather of destroying our
country by doing that very same thing
but it's not working
in in no small part because the white
house can't get on the same message here
this has been one of the
toughest aspects of the biden
administration is one you have no idea
what joe biden's going to say every time
he opens his mouth it's another
catastrophe for the communications
department and two the various
parts of the the white house of the
executive branch never seemed to be on
the same page so joe biden comes out he
says the 2022 midterms easily could be
illegitimate jen saki comes out he says
joe biden did not say that the elections
are not going to be illegitimate and
then kamala harris goes on tv and says
yeah i guess he said that sorry whoops
let's talk about another comment the
president made he openly cast doubt on
whether the 2022 midterm elections would
be legitimate he said it all depends um
which is astonishing to hear
a president question whether our
elections will be legitimate we've heard
it before but not from this president
is he really concerned that that we may
not have fair and free
elections the president has been
consistent on this issue and the issue
at hand the issue i was there last night
in the chamber of the senate
and the issue is that there are two
bills
the john lewis voting rights act and the
freedom to vote act
that have been
the the solution that has been offered
to address the fact that around our
country states have put in place laws
that are purposely making it more
difficult for the american people to
vote laws which will be felt by at least
55 million americans regardless of their
party affiliation their race their
gender or their geographic location
and then this answer goes on for another
three minutes no no but i'm hold on how
how are the elections being stolen how
is the election illegitimate and kamala
harris just keeps on going with the same
platitudes yes yes she's just one day
behind the talking points but i think
she's giving the more honest answer
at least in terms of what the democrats
actually believe i think joe biden is
giving a more honest answer
not in terms of the reality but in terms
of what the democrats believe and the
reality is this
the elections are legitimate when the
democrats win them and the elections are
illegitimate when the democrats lose
them
i don't think that i am caricaturing the
democrat position on this i think they
they truly believe that and the reason
they believe that is not just because of
whatever logical pretzels they've got to
twist themselves into to say that the
way that ballots are counted or the way
the ballots are collected only happen in
a fair way when the democrats win and in
an unfair way when the democrats lose
it's in the very nature of the democrats
winning or losing itself namely
that when
even when the people go out and vote for
republicans
that is a threat to democracy because
the people have been misled
the people have been led astray by
misinformation the people are laboring
under a false consciousness
so they think that they want to vote for
republicans but that's only because the
republicans have brainwashed them into
voting against their interests that that
that itself is
illegitimate because progress only goes
in one direction
they have a vision of progress
and so
if you are impeded from
moving further along that path toward
progress
something had to go wrong
and because the left conflates the ideas
of democracy liberalism and progress
because it's all the same because the
people if they were truly free to make
their their choices they would obviously
vote for progress and for the democrats
because of that
when the people do something that the
democrats don't like that is a threat to
our democracy there is there is a
twisted logic there it's not just pure
power-hungry interest politics
but but it shows you that democracy does
not mean what what they think that it
means it reminds me of max boot who
yesterday said that the people voting a
certain way is a grave threat the people
in america moving from the left to the
right from democrat to republican poses
a grave threat to democracy
on the surface it seems to undermine the
point but there is something deeper here
and it is why
the left is so vicious it's why they are
willing to do anything to win these
elections
because
goodness truth
justice democracy everything good in
this country
in in the vision of the democrats rides
on them winning the elections and so any
means to do that
is justified
now
when i have an end in mind to i don't
know
buy a part for my car or truck
the means that i'm going to use to get
to that end
to realize that end are very simple it's
not a tough question i go to
rockauto.com in the year of our lord
2022
you do not need to be wasting time at
the auto parts store at the actual brick
and mortar shop just think about this
you need a part for your car or truck
you get in your car you drive well if
you can get in your car maybe your car's
broken and you can't make it
if you can you drive
15 20 minutes to the auto parts store
you go in you wait online that's another
10 minutes then you talk to the guy
behind the counter you you tell him what
parts you want for your car he goes into
the back they probably don't have the
car part there's just too many car parts
these days too many makes and models he
comes back he says no we're gonna have
to order it you have to wait another i
don't know week you drive home the 15
minutes you wait the week you have to go
drive back to pick up them don't do that
when you can go to rock auto rock auto
makes it so easy family owned company
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years
you can save 30
50
sometimes on these auto parts you get
the same prices for pros and
do-it-yourselfers
it's never gimmicky it's not that you
have to log in on tuesday morning and
you'll say 15 no it's always reliably
low prices head on over there right now
why spend up to twice as much for the
same parts go to rockauto.com right now
see all the parts available for your car
or truck then write knowles k-n-w-l-e-s
in their how did you hear about this box
so they know that we sent you
speaking of blunders that joe biden has
talked himself into
joe biden discussing the potential
illegitimacy of the election is not
the dumbest most catastrophic thing that
he said in recent days that would
probably be joe biden's invitation
practically speaking invitation to the
russians to invade ukraine
russia will be held accountable
if it invades and it depends on what it
does it's one thing if it's a minor
incursion and then we end up having to
fight about what to do and not do etc
but if they actually do what they're
capable of doing with the force of mass
on the border it is going to be a
disaster for russia if they further
engrade you i wanted to follow up
briefly on a question asked by bloomberg
you said that russia would be held
accountable if it invades and it depends
on what it does are you saying that a
minor incursion by russia into ukrainian
territory would not lead to the
sanctions that you have threatened or
are you effectively giving putin
permission to make a small incursion
into the country
good question
um
that's how it did sound like didn't
it yeah
when i when i said that we wouldn't do
anything if russia only invades part of
ukraine i guess it sounded like i i said
that that russia could invade part of
ukraine
yeah i guess
anyway moving on next question
it sounded like that because that's
that's exactly what you said and he
doesn't he doesn't even try to correct
it this is probably
the worst case scenario
because
here
joe biden is is not
standing firm with ukraine and saying do
not invade russia they're going to be
serious consequences if you invade
ukraine
and he he's not even rolling over and
saying okay just come ukraine is yours
now i'm just going to give you ukraine
he's he's in this awful middle ground
where he's saying okay russia
you can you can roll those tanks in
and you can take some small part of
ukraine and you can kill some people and
you can shoot some bullets but not too
many
not too much
or
else
uh
uh
or else what
i never want to hear about russian
collusion again
it was always so crazy that the
democrats accused republicans of
colluding with the russians after
democrats spent a full century colluding
with the russians from the communist
revolution in russia up until today the
left has been colluding with the
russians
they wanted warmer relationships with
the russians they opposed attempts to
stop russian expansion they opposed
ronald reagan's policy in the cold war
for instance to outspend the russians to
destroy the soviet union ronald reagan
was asked what's what's your strategy on
the cold war he said it's a simple
strategy we win and they lose the left
lost their minds over that hillary
clinton when she was secretary of state
begged for a russian reset she wanted
warmer relations with russia
i think that there are good arguments
for
warming up relations with russia to play
off of china for instance i don't think
that's the left's game because i think
the left is sucking up to china even
more than they are to russia
but the idea that republicans are
somehow softer on russia than the
democrats is
absurd
and here we have the clearest example of
that joe biden inviting russia to invade
what is today
an independent nation ukraine more proof
that the left projects and it's a really
important lesson because when you're in
the moment of of getting some accusation
from the left your your instinct is to
defend your instinct is to take it
seriously your instinct is to try to
reason your way out of it
i don't think you have to do that when
the left comes out and calls you a
racist probably the clearest example you
don't need to defend yourself you don't
need to explain to them why you're not a
racist
the democrat party is
deeply deeply racist
it views politics through the lens of
race much much more so than republicans
do the democrats are advocating policies
which create racial hierarchies and
reward some races and punish other races
you don't need to take it seriously when
they call you that just laugh at them
maybe
give them a couple of words that aren't
happy birthday and go on your merry way
certainly the same thing is true with
when they tell you that
the republicans are colluding with
russia you don't need to you don't need
to explain how you're not really
colluding with russia and actually trump
was misunderstood when he said this or
that just laugh at them
they're just projecting they've been
colluding with russia for a century
nowhere is the left's projection clearer
than on the science we've got some great
great news
from the cdc
the first level of the news is that the
cdc has concluded that natural immunity
is better than the vaccine at fighting
the delta variant of the coronavirus but
that's not the best news
the best news as far as i'm concerned
about this headline
is that we were right yet again we were
right yet again it was only the
conservatives who for the past two years
really have said that natural immunity
offers strong protection against viruses
and specifically against the coronavirus
we suspected that natural immunity would
work
we were laughed at we were called idiots
we were called anti-science rubes we
were called conspiracy theorists and oh
there it is oh we were right
because the difference between the truth
and a conspiracy theory these days would
appear to be six to nine
months
this
headline that natural immunity
is is stronger protection against the
delta variant than the covid vaccines
that was a conspiracy theory
two days ago
two days ago that was considered by the
media by big tech by the administrative
agencies by elected politicians that was
a conspiracy theory today they admit
that it's the truth
this has happened again and again
the cdc
the
fda dr fauci joe biden even
have been caught in this time and time
again
the cloth masks
right-wingers said the cloth masks don't
really do very much to protect against
covid we're all called conspiracy
theorists and then in the last couple of
weeks
the public health officials admit the
cloth masks actually don't do don't do
very much
the conservatives said that kovid almost
certainly escaped from the wuhan
laboratory
we were called conspiracy theorists what
happens turns out that was completely
correct
which raises the question
what is considered a conspiracy theory
today that we are going to find out
tomorrow is the truth
do we do we think this is it we've
reached the end of the road it reminds
me of of people who
who believe that everything is
completely above board in the
intelligence agencies right governments
need intelligence services i'm not
saying that america can do without
intelligence services
but sometimes the things that the ic
does are a little bit shady
and now they're all being defended by
the liberal establishment it's not the
conservatives who are defending the fbi
and the cia it's the liberals who are
defending them
the liberals who previously would point
out the the cia in the 1960s they
performed these experiments these dodgy
unethical experiments on these people
and they did this and they invaded this
country and they overthrew this
government and they did this thing that
was illegal and they did all but
but i bet they've just stopped doing all
of that now right
i bet but i bet right now all of the
declassified documents that we see from
what these agencies have been doing in
the past are pretty dodgy and you really
they should have probably been rained in
but they probably just stopped
all of these lies from from the left
from the liberal establishment from the
science
but that's probably just stopped right
now everything's going to be above board
no we have to think for ourselves
because conspiracy theories today are
going to be the truth tomorrow
specifically when it comes to the public
health technocracy that keeps lying to
us
now moving out of the realm of policy
into the realm of culture
m m's
have gone trans
they're trans they're not they're not
transitioning from one sex to another
sex
they're not transitioning necessarily
from dark chocolate to milk chalk let's
say
certainly not white chocolate could you
imagine how racist that would be but the
m ms
are going woke
mars incorporated the candy company that
owns m m's
gave an announcement yesterday they said
we took a deep look at our characters
both inside and out and have evolved
their look personalities and backstories
to be more representative of today's
society as the world changes so do we
the characters are now going to have
quote a fresh modern take on their style
and
more nuanced personalities to underscore
the importance of self-expression and
power of community through storytelling
because today's quote more dynamic
progressive world
demands it
we are talking about
candy-coated chocolate bites and we are
getting a dissertation on the
progressive nature of our society
why are they doing this i actually think
there's something deeper going on in
this story than just the silliness of a
piece of candy going trans
mars says quote studies show our desire
to belong is as strong as our desire to
be loved and that desire is common for
all people irrespective of culture race
ethnicity geography or location again
this release coming from a candy bar
company they showed
the the mars company showed a glimpse of
this new program in an instagram video
they say we're on a mission to create a
world where everyone feels they belong
using the power of fun join us for all
fun kind head on over
so they're saying this world is
progressive so inevitably the world is
going to move more in the leftist
direction it's the same sort of thing
that joe biden and kamala harris and the
rest of the democrats are assuming when
they say that elections that they lose
will be illegitimate they're saying the
world is inevitably going to become more
progressive and it's good that it's
going to become more progressive and so
anytime that that progress or the
capital p is impeded
by definition something has gone wrong
by definition that election is
illegitimate but what what m ms are
pursuing right now what our society is
pursuing right now is two contradictory
objectives they say that they want more
self-expression they also say that they
want more commonality community and
sense of belonging you can't have both
you can't have both those are
at odds with one another and our culture
is radically pursuing both and it's why
we're tearing apart at the seams
eminem's
much like our cultural leaders our candy
and our cultural leaders want us to
pursue radical self-expression
meaning if you're a man and you think
you're a woman then you better dress up
in dresses you better wear high heels
you better rub some lipstick all over
your face frankly you should probably
mutilate your body you should go under
the knife you should pump yourself full
of hormones because that's your true
self-expression
now
i don't think that really is your
self-expression i think that yourself is
more than just your delusions i think
your body has something to do with
yourself i think reality has something
to say about yourself but
but but in the views of of our modern
world
the cultural leaders say whatever whim
or fancy you've got you need to express
that but also gosh we're all so lonely
we're also we're all so isolated we
don't even seem to be able to speak to
one another anymore we don't we don't
seem to speak a common language and so
what we really want also is community we
all want to be included we want to be
together
but if everybody is off
speaking their own language not talking
to one another not regarding the demands
or views of their neighbors if everyone
is off forming their own to quote
anthony kennedy in one of the dumbest
supreme court decisions ever planned
parenthood v casey which has a lot to do
with what we're talking about right now
because we're here in dc at the march
for live
if everyone's doing that
forming our own concept of existence
we can't have community
we've got to find a middle ground here
we've got we've got to
pick frankly because we've gone so far
in one direction that we don't have
anything left in the other we've gone so
far down the radical self-expression
rabbit hole that we we don't have any
community left anymore and so the answer
to this
is to limit self-expression the answer
to this is to place some limits upon
this mistaken view of liberty we have
which is nothing but licentiousness and
delusion it's a problem not just for the
left the left is pushing it obviously
it's a problem for the right too
we we too are pursuing a radical
individualism and it is tearing the
country apart at the seams
we need to recognize that license and
liberty are different things when when
the left talks about the liberty to go
get an abortion
they're describing a license there is no
such liberty
and that's what we're going to be
talking about over the next couple of
days this is the march for life it's the
49th
annual march for life
been going on every single year since
roe versus wade created a fictional
right to to an abortion
and there is a lot of hope this year
that roe vs wade is not going to make it
to 50. because there's a case before the
supreme court dobbs versus jackson
women's health organization which could
overrule roe and could overrule planned
parenthood v casey which was the case in
the 1990s that reaffirmed roe versus
wade
and do you know what's going to happen
then is that the end of the pro-life
movement no that's only the beginning of
the pro-life movement for for a long
time
for a long time
the conservatives said and the
originalists and the textualists they
said if roe versus weight is overturned
that is not going to outlaw abortion
around the country it's just going to
send it back to the states and if you're
in tennessee and you don't want abortion
you should be able to talk to your
fellow citizens talk to your legislators
pass a law and say no abortion and if
you're in new york and you're a bunch of
degenerates then you should be able to
talk to your neighbors persuade them
talk to your legislators and have
abortion up until the moment of birth
that's democracy in action and what the
left would say is you guys are being
disingenuous you don't really just want
to return this to the states you want to
outlaw abortion nationwide
and to that i say
yup
you got us guilty is charged yes it is
not enough
to it's wonderful we need to overturn
roe versus wade i'm very eager if we can
get that if we can send abortion back to
the states that's a great
step in the right direction but it's not
the end of it i don't really care about
the procedural victory of who decides
whether or not to kill kids i care to
some degree but it's not to be all and
end all what i really care about is the
substantive issue of ending abortion the
left focus is on progress
for the left progress is everything the
right
needs its own end in mind the right
needs to be able to focus on something
beyond mere compromise beyond mere
tactics beyond mere
procedure
what what the right needs to focus on is
justice
the left has progress they're moving
toward utopia what the right has is
justice abortion is simply wrong no one
has a right to do it
human rights are rights only by virtue
of their accord with right reason if a
right is an if a law is unjust it is no
law at all there is no right to an
abortion not at the national level not
at the state level not at the local
level not anywhere
not anywhere
and so we're very excited i really hope
that the supreme court makes the right
decision
and that will move us a step in the
right direction there will be a whole
lot more pro-life movement to go by the
way it's a political winner
i know that the swamp creatures here in
dc on the left and the right tell you
not to talk about abortion
so who cares about that especially the
ones on the republican side they said
just talk about cutting taxes don't talk
about the social issues the cultural
issues abortion is a huge winner there
was a poll that just came out from the
knights of columbus and uh marist
showing that 71 of americans support
legal limits on abortion 71
not saying to outlawed outright but
putting limits on abortion 71
49 of democrats support limits on
abortion 93 of republicans support
limits on abortion 70 of independents
support limits on abortion there is a
huge disconnect between what the
american people think about abortion and
what the elite media on the left and
frankly on the right too think about it
but the politicians who are listening to
this show do not listen to the elite
media do not listen to the swamp
creatures they're wrong they're wrong on
this issue they're wrong on crime the
majority of americans want more
criminals locked up the elite media the
elites on the left and the right
want to let criminals out of prison they
even got trump to pass a jailbreak bill
it was politically probably the
stupidest thing the guy ever did and and
tone deaf he's the guy's got a really
good sense of what his people want
but
he was persuaded
by these elites in dc
to undermine that the other one is
abortion the majority of americans want
to drastically reduce abortion the
elites on both sides don't want to do it
well abortion or immigration rather not
abortion abortion is
a similar
issue it's it's popular
to limit abortion even among young
voters there was a poll just released by
the students for life in america
found that most millennials and gen z
americans do not share abortions radical
to joe biden's radical abortion views i
sound like joe biden as i keep tripping
over this because it's a very important
issue
the poll found 80 percent of younger
americans believe that they should have
the right to vote on abortion-related
policies in their state
meaning the supreme court should not
not
acknowledge some national right to
abortion some constitutional right
eighty percent of gen z and millennials
that's up from 66 percent who gave that
response just
last year
abortion is the sacred it's a sacrament
really i suppose of the feminists and
the feminists broadened it out to the
left in in the 1960s
younger generations are less persuaded
by that and i i don't think there's it's
a coincidence
the feminists have peddled delusion
the feminists peddled this idea that men
and women are exactly the same and a
woman needs a man like a fish needs a
bicycle and people had to go along with
that and i think that the younger
generations millennials especially gen z
are not interested in delusion i think
this is why younger people when they
come into religion for instance when
they return to the church they tend not
to go to the happy touchy-feely
squishy churches they tend to go to the
orthodox churches they tend to go to the
hard-hitting truths i think that these
younger generations are much less
interested in autonomy
than
gen x and the boomers and i think
they're much more interested in truth
and we need to push for that
yes overturning roe versus wade would in
a way
diminish autonomy
we would have more political autonomy
meaning communities would have more of
the right to pass their own laws
women would have less personal autonomy
to
kill their own kids
but truth and justice would be served
the truth that the baby is a baby and
the baby should not just be killed
and the justice of the whole thing
it is simply wrong
everywhere it is simply wrong this is a
great example of conservatives using the
politics
to affect the culture
we just did it daily wire just did this
we sued the biden administration we
brought this lawsuit about joe biden's
osha mandate the court
granted our point and then starbucks
this major usually corporation starbucks
ends their own employer mandate
all because daily wire brought a lawsuit
up to the supreme court we used the
government and we found out that culture
sometimes is downstream of politics too
very important on the mandate it's very
important on our public health tyranny
much more important
on this issue of life so everyone who's
out there marching this is great hope to
see you out there but the march is just
beginning
now
speaking of sexual issues
you may have seen this video going
around of matt walsh
the best-selling lgbtq children's author
author of johnny the walrus he was
debating a transsexual individual on dr
phil's show
he asks that the transgender activist to
define the word woman and this person
could not do it
that's a question i would like to throw
out to you know other members of the
panel actually because just like the
four-year-old can't answer what is a
girl well this is one of the problems
with this left-wing gender ideology is
that no one who espouses it
can even tell you what these words means
like what is a woman
can you tell me what a woman is
no i can't
because it's not for me to say
womanhood looks different for everybody
what do you what do you define a woman
as an adult human female and what does a
female mean
uh
how do you define someone with with
female reproductive organs
okay someone who's you know here's the
thing when you're when you're female it
goes right down to your bones your dna
so that's why if someone
dies okay we could dig up their bones a
hundred years from now we have no idea
what they believed in their head but we
can tell what sex they were because it's
in it's down in it's it's ingrained in
every fiber of their being you stood up
here and said trans women are women yes
tell me what you mean what is a
womanhood is something that just as
ethan explained i cannot define because
i am not myself
so what did you mean when you said trans
women are women if you don't know what
it means right so here's the thing so i
do not define what a woman is because i
do not identify as a woman womanhood is
something that is an umbrella term it
includes people that describes what
people who identify as a woman i
identify as what as a woman what is that
the response to this clip has been
hilarious
matt as is often the case trended on
twitter for a very long time
all of this because of his book johnny
the walrus uh johnny the walrus sold out
within 48 hours don't worry more copies
are on the way you can reserve yours
today also speaking of good books that
you can order on amazon luke rosiak who
is the daily wired journalist who broke
the national story about sexual abuse in
the loudoun county public schools he's
got a new book coming out it's called
race to the bottom uncovering the secret
forces destroying america's public
school system you can pre-order it at
amazon today
head on over there luke rosiak's book
race to the bottom pre-order it on
amazon we'll be right back with the
mailbag
welcome back to my absolute favorite
time of the week when i get to hear from
you in the mailbag first question up
from sarah
i have to admit i have a hard time
totally agreeing with you on some of the
traditional roles of women however it
has gotten me thinking if a woman is in
her 20s and doesn't want kids yet
is she just not thinking enough of the
future i feel as though it's fine to
want to live life while you're young but
unfortunately for women we have a
shorter time to make the decision about
kids and a family so did feminism just
cause us to be short-sighted only for
women to find that it's too late once
we've had fun not sleeping around but
having the freedom to pursue things
outside of a family that's my thought at
least would love to hear yours sincerely
back to the future
yes
yes that is exactly what happened
you've hit the nail on the head sarah
that that is it
the libs convinced women
that having a child is a terrible burden
that should be avoided at all costs and
if you do if the condom breaks if all of
the contraception that's being pushed on
the culture if that fails then you
really ought to just kill your kid why
so that you have the freedom to go be a
middle manager at the widget factory
because
rocking the cradle you know the hand
that rocks the cradle is the hand that
rules the world that's what we used to
think about it that's terrible that
doesn't do anything raising a real life
human being that that was that was made
inside of you
that loves you more than anyone will
ever love you that loves you with
because you're his entire world
and raising that human being is much
less important than doing spreadsheets
for
mr smith at the widget factory that's
much more gratifying we were told
because then if you don't have any kids
and you don't have a family and you just
work at the widget factory then on
sundays you can go to brunch with your
girlfriends and you can drink bellini's
and you can have that avocado toast and
maybe you can go to yoga afterward
you're probably gonna want to go to yoga
before after you have that big brunch
and mimosas with the girls and then you
can go home to your very clean put
together very expensive new york city
apartment and not have any
responsibilities maybe you'll go out get
a couple more drinks and then you know
what you'll do the next day you'll go
right back to the widget factory and
make more money for mr smith and that's
supposedly
much more gratifying sarah frankly you
even fall into this
this trap a little bit in your question
you said
look i i realize that feminists are
doing this i realize this is kind of
dumb i'm seeing your perspective michael
but
but don't you think that
where's the exact line that you use
we have a shorter time to make a
decision about kids and a family so it's
fine to want to live life while you're
young but you've got to do these other
things too
as if having a kid is not living life as
if getting married is not living life
you have bought the bs premise
that the bellinis and doing the same
thing over and over and just living
through your own
interest what you think are your own
interests that that's living life and
then actually producing life or settling
down and having a family or frankly if
you don't want to get married
going into religious life or
consecrating your singlehood or becoming
a missionary or joining the military or
whatever that
that that is not living life
it's the opposite
when drew clavin makes this point when
you have a child it's not that your life
gets much much better in all ways it
does get a lot better but in some ways
your life gets kind of worse and more
difficult it's
it's not a better or worse thing you
just get more life you get if you want
to if we're really talking about living
your life you get a whole lot more of it
when you commit to society settle down
and especially if you if you are lucky
enough to to have kids
from benji all right my my rant is my
sermon is over from benji hey michael
thank you for making the show i listen
often i have a question relating to a
friend of mine she says it happened
where she dreams and the things she
dreamed about
comes true for example she had a dream
about a conversation with her family and
six months later the conversation
happened and she finished her family
members sentences that's creepy now
we're both christians do you have any
idea why this happens could you
enlighten me thanks
well
there's more between heaven and earth
than is dreamt of in our philosophy
horatio
and
also
as a christian you you believe in
providence
you believe in
in the world working in such a way that
that there is a logic to it
that god and his omniscience knows all
of things because he's outside of time
and space
and that we
have our free will
but also there is such a thing as grace
there is also such a thing as providence
there's a great line from alexander pope
who says
all nature is but art unknown to thee
all chance direction which thou canst
not see
these queen this is a line that my
friend father george rutler mentions in
a book called coincidentally about all
of these strange historical coincidences
it's a delightful book but
what's going on with your sister i don't
know might might just be a coincidence
might be the veil of providence you know
getting a little peek through there
but it's a wonderful thing whenever
these sorts of
coincidences providence whenever you see
providence like this i really love it
because it reminds me
not that it tells me my future not that
it tells me that i have to go do this
thing and not this thing necessarily
just reminds me that
god is there there is such a thing as
providence there is a plan
that's a great comforting fact from nate
michael i have a friend that used to be
a very strong christian was was highly
active in her church but now says she no
longer believes in the christian god her
main arguments are that she feels that
god cannot be all powerful and all good
she says this because if god created
everything then he had to create sin as
well she also believes that if god is
all-powerful that human beings are
simply robots following orders and don't
actually have free will i'd love to hear
how you would respond to this matter
well she's clever
because i think she's probably realized
the problem in her
logic and so she's trying to make up for
that problem by denying a facet of
reality namely she says that if god is
all-powerful then god had to create sin
but that's not true
not only is that not necessary but
that's not what happened and that's not
what's in the bible and that's not what
christians believe
what god could also have done that he
actually did do
is he could have created beings made in
the image and likeness of god with free
will
and those beings having free will
could turn away from god
which is the essence of sin
and then sin and death could pervade the
world as they did not through god's
making
but
through the
poor choices of of human beings with
free will
so your friend i think intuiting this
says okay well there we go free will
answers that so then i've got to just
deny free will
she says that if god is all-powerful
human beings are simply robots and don't
have free will
why
why is that the case why does that fall
if god is all-powerful why can't he
create a being with free will
now
so i your friend's argument doesn't make
a lot of sense at all because free will
simply answers that now you you might
say okay well if god is
all-powerful or
even even more to the point if god is
all-knowing if he's omniscient then how
on earth do human beings have free will
if he knows what you're going to do
before you do it then are you really the
one making that choice
yes you are
the way that you can resolve this
tension is that god is outside of time
and space so god is seeing all things
that have ever happened and will ever
happen
outside of that linear progression of
time
that's one way to try to visualize this
obviously you're not going to be able to
comprehend it because we're living in
time and space and this is very a tough
concept to wrap your head around
some
christian heretics want to
want to resolve this problem by denying
free will
some christian heretics want to resolve
this problem by denying grace and
providence or god's omniscience or
whatever
the real answer
is that free will and
grace work together
they exist together i once heard it
described as
as being like a waltz
when one is waltzing
you can't always quite tell
which partner is leading the other
partner you can one it just they kind of
dance very gracefully
together from kate
i have an unusual problem michael
oh my i've struggled with large breasts
my whole life i know the first reaction
guys have when they hear this i guess i
just demonstrated that reaction however
it can be difficult to work out clothes
are a struggle and more importantly i
have chronic back pain what is the
general christian consensus on surgeries
like breast reductions and even breast
implants well those would be two
different
those would be two different issues on
the question of a breast reduction if
it's a medical problem
and you're having a surgery to improve
your health and solve a medical problem
there would be nothing wrong with that
if
and you can bring in breast implants on
this aspect of the question because i
don't see how getting breast implants
would help your problem it seems like it
would hurt your problem
if
if the reason that you're having breast
surgery or any other kind of cosmetic
surgery is for your own vanity
if it's for your own
uh
desire to incite lust among people uh
that would be no good
if you're having a breast surgery like
breast implants for instance that
destroy
mammary glands that destroy working
organs that that would be no bueno that
is that's not something that you would
be
you would be permitted to do in the
christian understanding of things but if
you're going to get the surgery just
because you're you're going to break
your back otherwise that's perfectly
fine you don't have anything to worry
about there
from dan
michael another relationship question
here it's all these relationship
questions
related to my friend group from high
school i'm vaccinated one of our friends
is not which has caused my other more
coveted crazy friends to ostracize not
only him but me as well since we live
together
they've started to use seeing them as a
carrot to try to get our friend to take
the fouchy algae saying that they would
want to hang with him if he would only
get the jab to me this is pretty
unspeakable because i would never
abandon my friends regardless of our
differences and i refuse to let this be
the wedge that ends 10 years of
friendship why are they choosing this
moment in the pandemic to make a big
deal about the vaccine and what are some
strategies to convince them to switch
direction on this bs sincerely you can't
make new old friends you can
but you can't
you can't have a one-sided friendship
either
it takes two to tango and if your
friends are saying that their cult of
of public health is more important to
them than your friendship or
than their friendship with your roommate
then
that's their call
and you you can't debase yourself by
saying please be friends with us please
come on please guys and i i wouldn't and
i wouldn't inject yourself with an
experimental drug just to try to win the
approval of your friends they're doing
it because they've convinced they've
been convinced by the media and by the
liberal establishment more broadly that
this is a holy crusade that they're
saving the world by
telling everyone to take this new drug
to to avoid getting the cough
but
they seem sincerely to believe that and
when people adopt new religions when
they take on new religious views
especially when they join a cult
one thing that goes along with that very
often is they're told to break their old
relationships
this is true even beyond
these awful kinds of cults it's true
if a guy's hanging out with a bunch of
drunks and he's a drunk himself and then
he decides to get sober and he goes to
alcoholics anonymous one of the first
things he's going to be told to do is to
stop hanging out with all his drunk
friends at three in the morning to to
break some of those toxic relationships
because it's going to be much harder to
recover without them
when you join a cult the cult leader
will tell you don't talk to your friends
and family anymore because it's gonna
that's going to
pull this new initiate away from the
cult
and your friends are dealing with that
with their cult leader dr fauci you
can't do anything about it i'm sorry to
hear it you're right you can't make new
old friends but your friends sound like
a bunch of schmuck so try to wait it out
but i i
i don't think you're going to
necessarily reason them out of this if
they
if they choose your friendship over dr
fauci that's a wonderful thing and if
they don't too bad for them
from jake mr knowles i got into a
discussion with some friends about lucid
dreaming i had always thought it was a
random thing but some people practice
and do tricks to help bring about this
state of dreaming this sparked a debate
on lucid dreaming being demonic and not
something to be messed with what are
your thoughts on lucid dreaming lucid
dreaming is when
it's when you're having a dream but
you're aware that you're in the dream
and so
well really what what that means is you
can just sleep with that lady that you
find attractive
i think that's what you're getting to
you that if you're in this state of
lucid dreaming you can commit a sin
and it's not really a sin because
you're not really doing it because
you're dreaming
the
this is a complicated issue because if
you
sleep with the cute chicky in your lucid
dream which i think we all know is what
what what is being discussed here or
maybe it's much worse than that maybe
you commit a murder in your that guy
that really drives you crazy in class or
at work and you just kill him and stab
him in your lucid dream that would be
even worse you are not actually
committing the murder you are not
actually committing fornication or
adultery with the cute chicky but but
you can be sinning
if you
are engaging in an act of the will
so if you are practicing lucid dreaming
and trying to bring this about so that
you can
you are actually using your will to
entertain impure desires to to bring
about all of these fantasies willfully
then you are committing a sin and you
shouldn't do that and it's creepy there
are
more interesting things you can do with
your life than just trying to dream
about how you can fly or do less
also delusional but less savory things
uh final question this one actually i
guess is related from noah dear prophet
knowles i want some advice on how to
overcome the first days weeks and months
of porn addiction i've tried to quit
countless times i can't seem to overcome
these first moments porn free the urges
are so strong i can't comprehend how it
gets easier with time as it only seems
harder after each day how should i deal
with living porn free during the hardest
part of quitting well your question
is true for any addiction
you could replace the word porn with
heroin or drinking or cigarettes or food
or anything that you are
abusing food is not
wrong to consume in and of itself but it
can be abused to the point of of even
being like an addiction so how do you
deal with that
well there are some really practical
steps you can take
that i've had two friends who have had
full-blown
porn addictions where they actually sort
of needed to get on a recovery plan to
get out of it it was causing lots of
problems in their life physical problems
social problems and so there are
there are resources available you can
put little gizmos on your browser so
that you know if you go look at the
naughty website it'll send a text to
your mom and you probably don't want
that to happen that would be one thing
to do
one thing from the catholic perspective
that i would say if you're trying to
break any kind of habitual sin is go to
confession it's the laundromat for the
souls and whether you believe that there
is something spiritually edifying about
that i obviously believe that there is
but even if you think that's all bunk i
will just tell you as a practical matter
when you need to get on your knees and
tell a priest
all the dirty rotten terrible things you
do that is quite an inducement not to do
them anymore because when you want to do
them when you when you have the impulse
to do that in your case i guess looking
at porn you will think huh i don't want
to have to go and tell the priest that i
did that or i don't want to have an
email sent to my mother or my friend or
my wife or my buddy
or anything anything else like that so
you can set some practical things in
place you also need to recognize that
you're probably
going to stumble if you're in this
full-blown kind of addiction you're
probably going to stumble don't let the
stumble lead you down a binge don't
don't let the fact that you've been
sober for 20 years and you have a beer
and now you're going to go on a
three-week bender don't do that if you
have the beer that's wrong you shouldn't
have done that it's a risk it's the near
occasion of sin but just stop
you you can stop and you have to
recognize that
moral culpability
for habitual sins
is
is less less strong
because you you you're not in full
command of your will and so you've gotta
work on that you gotta you gotta work to
develop your addiction well you gotta
work to get out of that addiction you
gotta work to cultivate those virtues so
i wouldn't go too hard on yourself but i
would make sure that you do not put
yourself in the near occasion of sin if
you always look at porn in some room of
your house don't spend time in that room
if you always look at porn on one device
or another don't use that device as much
set up those safeguards and
you're not the only one struggling with
this so
recognize porn is all around the culture
unlike heroin which by the way
heroin at least for now is is illegal
something like porn is everywhere it's
actually encouraged so it's very
difficult but stay strong you're one of
the
many hundreds of people who have written
in with this exact question on here
other people are obviously struggling
with it too and wish you the best of
luck i'm michael knowles it's the
michael dole show see you monday
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin